des clients accueillis sous les
applaudissements et une files d'attentes
devant certains magasins dès 10 heures
ce matin mon grand plaisir faisait le
plein chèvre acheteuse accompagnée d'une
certaine curiosité
on a vu ce centre se construire petit à
petit depuis le début et que là on a vu
il ya quelques jours qu'il allait ouvrir
et comme il est assez futuriste et qu'on
a vu des photos sur internet sur le
facebook de la ville de plaisir ça nous
a donné envie d'aller voir en vrai j'ai
le travail à faire encore alors si pour
ça j'ai vu naître toi un petit peu comme
ça je prends la queue et j'ai eu lieu
j'ai fait mes courses mais peu vite et
comme ça j'ai gagné deux temps ça
faisait un moment que je passais devant
quand j'ai vu la structure du centre
commercial
je me suis dit que c'était quelque chose
de gros qu'ils avaient fait donc porter
aux tgv voulu me roy on a entendu parler
des depuis très longtemps on a vu
comment ça s'est passé comment les
travaux se dérouler et puis aujourd'hui
voilà avec la publicité on vient voir de
nous mêmes à 39 mille mètres carrés 40
boutiques des moyennes et des grandes
surfaces
parmi les têtes de gondole le
distributeur irlandais prime marque
nous n'avions pas du tout de magasins
dans l'ouest parisien
c'est le 7ème magasin dans la région
parisienne mais c'est le premier sur
cette zone là et pour nous avec le
nombre d'habitants qui lie à dans cette
région c'était indispensable d'être là
une ouverture retardée kovy 19 oblige
après six mois de retard le centre
commercial a été inaugurée mercredi en
soirée la conclusion d'un projet débuté
il ya huit ans par la compagnie de
phalsbourg
on est content de ce moment et cela
montre que dans notre pays malgré le coc
vide malgré la crise économique et bien
on peut investir puisque je rappelle que
nous avons créé 800 emplois dont 600
emplois nets nouveau c'est aussi un
bilan positif pour l'emploi c'est un
bilan pour le bien-être des habitants
puisque nous avons créé trois passages
pour désenclaver
le quartier de l'aqueduc des boutiques
sont encore en cours d'installation le
multiplexe ugc n'ouvrira lui qu'au
premier semestre 2021
le centre accueillera bientôt un pôle
médical est l'une des médiathèques de
plaisir c'est un déplacement de la
médiathèque est actuellement dans dans
le château de plaisir et qui va
déménager pour venir ici puisque nous
avons aussi des travaux qui doivent
commencer dans le château de plaisir et
donc pendant cette période intermédiaire
la médiathèque va venir s'installer ici
et on verra bien comment les choses se
passent pour ensuite créer aussi un
centre numérique au niveau du château de
plaisir conçu par l'architecte j'admire
à naulleau mon grand plaisir a demandé
un investissement de 150 millions
d'euros